What's being called an attempted coup
in the African nation of Sudan.
Residents of the country's capital
say today has been
the heaviest day of shelling
since the outbreak of violence
began last week in the United Nations.
Says at least
180 people were killed
there over the weekend.
CNN's Nima Elbagir reports for us now.
Even hospitals have come under fire
Sudan's military
with a show of strength over
the capital, Khartoum,
as well
as birdsong and artillery fire across
this country roiled in recent years
by conflict and coups is once again
the plaything of strongmen.
And what the military is calling
an attempted coup.
Abdel Fattah Al-burhan, Sudan's military
leader, is fighting for dominance
with Mohamed Hamdan Dagalo,
known as Hamad,
who leads the paramilitary rapid
support forces
which gained notoriety
in the western Darfur region.
And it is the most vulnerable
who are paying a price
to doctors.
Organizations say
that in Khartoum,
both sides
have hit hospitals in the fighting
At least
half a dozen, though both sides deny it.
CNN obtained eyewitness accounts
from doctors
on the ground
who told CNN
that the paramilitary rapid support force
directly targeted a hospital
where wounded armed forces soldiers
and their families were being treated,
including one doctor
who says she witnessed the ISAF approach.
And MAALIM Hospital in central Khartoum
relaxed, sending my husband understand
I mean,
I have to be strong enough
to speak to you.
You're the one that's going
to tell the world what's happening to us.
The evacuation was chaos.
We were running
as soldiers were shouting, run.
And then someone else would
yell, Stop, it's not safe.
But what choice did we have
Three separate
doctors there
describe to us
coming under intense bombardment.
The country's
central committee of doctors
tells CNN that with no doctors
to tell them,
the dead and injured
are left to rot in their beds.
And the Sudan Doctors Trade Union
called the targeting of hospitals
and the housing of military personnel.
The a clear breach
of international humanitarian law.
A charge both sides deny
Both military leaders now
fighting for control
were key allies
in subverting the country's
nascent democracy.
After the popular uprising in 2019,
which deposed Sudan's longtime
dictator Omar al-Bashir,
who now languishes in prison.
The memories of those protests
and the symbolic photo
that became
its emblem
are slowly fading,
as has the promised transition
from military
to democratic civilian rule.
Another said on Monday on Saturday.
But in an
interview with CNN
from Inside
Army HQ, the leader of Sudan's
military tells me
that the RPF militia
is staging an attempted coup with I'm
still not happy with my earlier
as we head into the campaign.
I want to
give Monken a shot.
I asked him
why the Sudanese people should trust him,
given his previous partnership
with Commander Dexter in a shop where
in Sudan where
the US will play.
General Burhan also committed
to a return to civilian rule.
The leader of the rapid support forces
also told CNN this weekend that he wanted
to ensure Democratic rule
that I don't want
to be the leader of the Army.
There's a framework agreement
between all the Sudanese stakeholders
that should be adhered to.
I don't want to lead anything
Neither General could tell
us when the people of Sudan
could expect this deadly fight to end.
While many languish without water,
food, electricity,
and no way to bury their dead.
Secretary of State Antony Blinken
has repeated his calls for calm,
joining other world leaders
but neither he nor those
standing alongside him
in these calls
appear to have any way
to deliver on them currently.
And there really is no end in sight
at the moment. Jake.
All right.
Now, Barker,
thank you so much for
that report as always.